pressing on through an election brexit
and covid to here
what's the plan prime minister
not that long to get things on course
before the next election today hoping
after two years as pm to turn a corner
walking down the aisle to renew his vows
with his party
a room specially built for him the tory
showman the undisputed star of this
conference
[Applause]
this
all unthinkable nine months ago
isn't it amazing to be back here in
person it's the first time since the
general election of 2019
when we finally sent that cordroid
communist cosmonaut
into orbit where he belongs
also seeking credit for postcovid
unlocking at the expense of a cabinet
colleague filmed on the dance floor last
night and on july the 19th we decided to
open every single theater
and every concert hall and nightclub in
england so we sent top government
representatives to our sweatiest wat de
nuit
to show that anyone could dance
perfectly safely
and wasn't he brilliant my friend
let's hear it
let's hear it for john von goby
living proof
defending tories doing things
differently that also means justifying a
big tax rise does anyone seriously
imagine that we should not now be
raising the funding to sort this out is
that really the view of responsible
conservatives i can tell you something
margaret thatcher would not have ignored
the meteorite that has just crashed
through the public finances thatcher's
still a hero but scathing towards tories
in number 10 immediately before him when
i stood on the steps of downing street i
promised to fix this crisis and after
decades of drift and dither and we are
going to deal with the biggest
underlying issues of our economy and
society the problems that no government
has had the guts to tackle before then
boris johnson's big argument today a
brexit-enabled revolution in this
country's economic model too bold for
any predecessor we are embarking now on
a change of direction that has been long
overdue in the uk economy we're not
going back to the same old broken model
with low wages low growth low skills and
low productivity all of it enabled and
and assisted by uncontrolled immigration
forever dazzling the audience that stuck
with him through brexit in the election
with his blinding optimism that was the
change that people voted for in 2016 and
that was the change that people voted
for again powerfully in 2019 and to
deliver that change we will get on with
our job
of uniting and leveling up across the uk
big on vision and values but only one
new policy to keep and retain teachers
instead the prime minister pitching
himself alongside recent british success
stories and we need the spirit of the
nhs nurses the spirit of the footballers
who took england into the final of a
major knockout tournament that is the
spirit that is the same across this
country in every town and village and
city that can be found in the hearts and
minds of kids growing up everywhere and
that is the spirit we are going to
unleash
thank you all thank you
boris johnson unleashed means boosterish
patriotism ripping on the successes of
british scientists and sportsman today
the prime minister was the nation's
columnist in chief but after a blizzard
of promises will people feel that they
live in the vision of britain that
forest johnson outlined today by the
time of the next election
he has an army of ardent supporters i
thought it was a great speech and as i
say very positive looking forward to the
future boris johnson's optimism isn't
always matched outside the hall there
are big problems do you think he was
ignoring the experience of normal people
not at all he's setting out the
challenges that we face he recognizes
those challenges he's got a vision of
how to solve them and i think that's uh
that's great for the country probably
one of the best speeches i've heard
better it was amazing for over an hour
it was funny and to the point he's very
interested in infrastructure but i did
notice that when he was talking about
connecting the cities of the north and
the midlands he did not mention high
speed too primary colours relentless
optimism just how long will it all work
for sam coates sky news manchester